[Music]
he did have a response ready no doubt
about it you heard the ingredients the
ingredients was overwhelmed you know
what I mean I know for a fact that would
have been bad for cutting it wouldn't be
good you know from his be on music at
that point
looks like Drake probably won't be
dropping another dish track aimed at
pusha t for Kanye West's sake his
producer James Prince revealed on sway
in the morning he called the hotline
bling' rapper to end his feud would push
a t you talked with Drake and you told
him to no longer respond duplicity right
right because that the pusher put out
the last joint that was added on you
felt like it crossed the line yeah yeah
definitely I feel like it crossed the
line what music was concerned you know
what I mean the disrespect for his
mother disrespect your father walked
away in five hell of a day marriage is
something to Cindy never had Drake how
you will win over she keep coming in the
last places apparently J Prince says the
unreleased song in response to Pusha was
so bad it could have ruined Kanye's
career after even speaking with Kanye
your honor may even cause spoke with the
brother and he didn't want this you know
the main and I saw this going in a place
that I feel would have ended his career
if Craig would have put out song
you know and definitely would have hurt
families and you know what I mean and we
not we not in it for that you know the
mean it's not great character I think
you know we're not in business to to at
our brother fellow man now you know to
that extent I'm wondering since it was
made if there's a chance that could
eventually leak no no no I don't think
it would leak because uh you know he
gave his word you know and me knowing
break like I know I'm you know he has a
word what kind of stuff that he said
[Music]
[Applause]